one of the things that was announced
last week around uh bitcoin was bitcoin
mining
uh for an ira account and so
if you understand how to get bitcoin
people always ask me how do i get more
bitcoin well you can do
three things you can either buy bitcoin
you can
earn bitcoin or you can mine bitcoin
right
and so buying it means you take fiat
dollars and you convert it into bitcoin
mining it means you take fiat dollars
you buy machines
computational power and you leverage
that or rent that to the network and it
pays you in exchange for
that computing power or the third thing
is you can earn it meaning that
joe owns a business i call up joe i say
you know what i'm great at doing a b or
c
uh task will you please pay me in
bitcoin and he decides whether he's
going to pay me in bitcoin or not
buy it earn it mine it those are the
three ways to get bitcoin and so
last week ira provider choice which i'm
a very big fan of
i actually have an account at choice
uh where uh i own gbtc in the account
that's pretty much all i own
um the ira provider choice and compass
mining announced last week that they're
offering an ira that will allow miners
to generate crypto
into a tax advantaged account now this
is really interesting because
we're going to get to some stats in a
minute that show that the ira accounts
in america
and the retirement uh kind of status of
americans
is very bad shocking uh and so what this
is going to allow people to do
is it's going to allow people to mine
bitcoin
and then have it deposited into that
retirement account
and so if it goes into your retirement
account rather than let's say a
non-retirement account you normally
would have to pay
income tax if it went into your regular
account but if you mine it and it goes
into your retirement account the thesis
here is that you will not have to pay
income tax on it it will essentially be
almost a contribution to the ira account
and then it can grow tax-free in these
accounts and depending on which type of
account you put it in you will either
get taxed on the out
when you take it out or not and so the
idea is
uh a customer first needs to buy mining
hardware uh by using assets within the
ira so key piece is you have to buy the
hardware
in with assets in the ira and then the
equipment is ranging from five to ten
thousand dollars
compass handles the logistics from
delivering those machines to data
centers to configuring and monitoring
the gear
and then if clients subsequently choose
to sell the capital gains taxes will be
deferred or eliminated completely
if done within the ira so you basically
take ira
dollars or retirement dollars you buy
machines those machines then
generate income but that income is held
within the retirement account and
therefore it is shielded from any sort
of capital gains tax it's either
deferred
or it's eliminated now that sounds like
an awesome idea
and if you're like bitcoin and you don't
want to buy it you don't want to earn it
this is a great way to get more bitcoin
because you can mine it
and you can do it in a tax advantage way
and as we've talked on the show ad
nauseum is one of the best ways to
increase your income is to simply
use the tax code to your advantage or to
kind of follow the rules of the tax code
but understand those rules
but not everyone agrees with this some
people claim that the income
generated from investing your ira funds
in mining crypto could be subject to
something called the unrelated business
income tax
if the mining is deemed a business or an
active trade and so
it is yet to be clear obviously choice
and compass believe that this is
shielded from those tax um kind of uh
clauses and aspects but some people
think that the unrelated business income
tax could apply here
but regardless what we see is the head
of tax strategy at
cointracker said quote it is just
another way
of earning income inside a self-directed
ira account because the advantage is
that you're not picking up income
you're just kind of saving for
retirement and so
if this is true and the irs does
recognize this as a way
for you to essentially save into your
retirement account
but not with dollars that you're
contributing instead it's using machines
that were bought with retirement dollars
to generate more income and get that
into that retirement account
it's a pretty interesting strategy like
i really like this i think this is
pretty freaking cool i'm interested to
see what happens in like the long term
in what way if it's deemed a business uh
or not right because you're buying
something that's generating income for
you
yes but is it a business if you buy a
computer i don't know i'm not a taxi it
could be a business
i'm not a tax attorney i'm not an
accountant i don't know what the answer
is but i think that it's super
interesting that people are considering
it
but just thinking out loud like how is
this that much different than what peter
thiel was doing with his ira well he put
shares yeah shares he did he didn't
uh i don't think that he took dollars
and there was no box shares no i don't
think he took dollars and bought the
shares yeah he just contributed i think
he contributed the shares that's one
main difference and two is
the income versus the capital
appreciation of the
equity itself right for those of you who
weren't here peter thiel has an ira
worth five
billion dollars despite
uh publication saying his net worth was
like two billion yeah
yeah i think peter jill's got a little
more than two billion um all right so
how bad is retirement in america the
best business show research team joe and
john
co-heads went and did a little digging
and news flash it is
horrible 2021 total contributions you
can make
for your traditional ira or roth ira
can't be more than
6 000 bucks or 7 000 if you're 50 or
older
and that's up from the 5 500 it was
previously
but you can't withdraw until you're 59
and a half and if you take it out
earlier you're
taxed what ends up being really
really sad is let's look at the
percentage of americans who have
no retirement savings
60 years old or older
13 more than
1 in 10 americans have no retirement
savings
and they're at retirement age not good
if you even look at
30 to 44 year olds one in four of them
have zero retirement savings and then
obviously if you look at younger people
it's almost 50 and so when you start to
look at this the younger people
we should expect them not to have a lot
of retirement savings
but to have zero is pretty shocking to
be in your mid twenties and have
zero dollars in your retirement savings
very very concerning
even if you put ten dollars a hundred
dollars a thousand dollars
something get started one out of every
two people can't possibly have
no retirement savings and then when you
start to move into kind of
more of your working age 30 to 44 to
still have one in four americans with
zero retirement savings i don't care if
you don't have great retirement or a lot
of money saved for retirement but to
have
zero at 30 to 44 is concerning and then
when you basically
get over 45 to still have 13 to 17
depending on your age to have zero
retirement savings i mean this is
really really concerning just a one
quick note is the average age of
retirement is 61 years old
61 not everyone always thinks of 62 but
it's actually 61. 61.
yeah it's all the young retirees pulling
down the average a little bit trying to
get a little lower
nobody's trying to retire later right so
it always seems to be everyone's trying
to retire earlier
uh all right then we're gonna look at
the average and median retirement
account balances and if we compare 2016
to 2019
you can see that uh the 2019
average retirement balance was 255
000 which 255 000
at uh retirement age of let's say 61
if you just live until you are
77 give or take which is the average
life expectancy
that means that you have 15 years of
which you basically have to live on 255
000
now if you've invested it correctly you
should be able to continue to
have it appreciate value hopefully you
can have it in some sort of cash
generating type return
so that you can actually drive income
off of it
maybe you're also pulling on social
security or some other type of
retirement program but to only have 255
000
and still have 15 plus years of life
until the average life expectancy
hits what you find is that an individual
would be living
on somewhere less than 20 000
per year that is very very difficult
that's below the poverty line
in america so the average retirement
balance
in america when you retire at the age of
61
ends up having less money in it than
what would meet the poverty line to live
just to the average life expectancy
that's not good that's really bad and
then when you look at the median
it's even worse so we're just gonna go
with the average which allows for things
like peter thiel's five
billion dollar retirement account to
pull the average up right the outliers
up
but really really really concerning
stuff so not only is there a high
percentage of population that has no
retirement savings
the people who do have some retirement
savings still super concerned
not to mention when you lose a
significant amount of your purchasing
power in a year like we just had this
past year
right 10 some people think inflation
wise
i saw a statistic we don't have the
charts uh unfortunately because i don't
know we're gonna talk about this
but uh one of the highest percentage of
people
who in march 2020 when the stock market
crashed you know 20
25 percent almost 30 percent uh
the high one of the highest percentage
of groups that sold
stock on the way down or at the bottom
were
retirees people later in life because uh
what they historically had known was
if you were buying stocks at let's say
the top of the dot-com bundle
uh bumble bubble then you basically had
almost a decade
until the stock market got back to those
levels um or you know
a number of years till you got there and
so what they said was i might not have
10 years left to make back this money
i'd rather just take the 20 haircut sell
the stocks get the cash and i'll just
live to fight another day
but then obviously what happened was as
they were selling the stock at depressed
levels or even at the bottom
then the stock market turned around and
ripped to all-time highs and
still even today is continues to hit
all-time high after all-time high almost
on a weekly basis
and so the people who are later in life
the guy with the global financial crisis
after the global financial crisis a lot
of that generation got uh completely
destroyed
financially or significantly hurt they
then became much more savers than
investors
through the first part of the longest
bull run in history and so they were
holding on to that they were saving they
didn't want to invest in the market they
were scared of another crash all that
type of stuff
then in 2015 16 17 18 they started to
invest more because they realized like
oh it's only going to go up
and right when they started to do that
2020 happens goes down they sell stock
because they're worried
and then the market rips on them again
it's really sad
but when you start to look at not only
do they not have a lot a lot
of or a high perc a higher percentage
than you would think
of retirees did not participate in the
what
hundred plus percent increase that we
see in the stock market over the last
you know 15 months
so i just looked up because one of the
charts i saw the other day that reminded
me of that was microsoft
and microsoft uh from the peak of the
dot-com bubble
it was at 55 or 60 a share and you're up
five six seven hundred percent
now from that time period but you didn't
recover and you weren't back uh
kind of in the profit until 2016. so 16
years it took you to recover
from uh the dot-com bubble so you had
people that
you know sold in 2008 sold in o5 sold in
2012
sold in 2015 whatever it might be they
ended up losing money on that trade
despite the stock being up 5 600 since
then
i mean it's just nuts right we've got
one more chart here
if we look and we see the median
retirement account balance by age
john found this chart john was john was
deep in the interwebs
uh i don't even know where you found
this one uh this is the 401k or ira
balance
35 to 44 37 000 55 to 64
only 100 grand right and i say only
realizing that
13 to 17 percent of people over the age
of 45 depending on your age have
zero 80 to 100 grand you cannot retire
on that
right like if you are relying on a
company pension
you are screwed if you are relying on
living
the last 20 years of your life at the
age of 55
on 100 grand in your retirement account
you are screwed you cannot do that
right what are you going to do live on 5
000 a year they're going to go to
another country
again you can do all kinds of stuff that
if you get in the situation or you are
in that situation today
there are things that you can do to
mitigate the damage or try to improve
your situation
but if you're a young person which most
of the people who watch this show are
young
do not make decisions that will put you
in a position at 55 years old
to be sitting there with a hundred grand
in your retirement so i just did the
math on this real quick from like an
educational perspective
so if you wait how do you do math from
an educational person no i'm saying i'm
going to tell you the example
for an educator because it's one thing
to say hey look this is terrible you
only have 80 to 100
000 you're not gonna be able to retire
but how do you fix that right so i just
did
uh if at 25 years old you start start a
roth ira you put in one thousand dollars
and then you contribute an extra one
thousand dollars per year
so less than uh a hundred dollars a
month right one
yeah one-sixth of what you're allowed to
though yeah one-sixth so you only do
not only but you do you start with one
thousand dollars and you contribute an
extra one thousand dollars per year
from the ages of 25 to 65. the average
stock market return over the last two or
three decades is ten percent
so if you compound allegedly allegedly
eight to ten percent yeah well it
depends what index you're looking at but
i use ten percent
for my math uh you'd end up math guy
your roth ira
at 65 would be 532 thousand dollars or
five times what the average is currently
or the median right now
okay so explain one thousand dollars you
start the ira with at 25 years old so
you put 1 000
you saved up however you got it you put
it in the ira then you contributed an
additional one thousand dollars
per year from 25 to 65. okay so that you
basically put forty thousand dollars in
plus your original thousand plus your
original
and then it compounds at ten percent
annual over that same time period
you would end with your roth ira and
ending balance of 532 thousand dollars
when you're 65
and 262 thousand dollars of that would
be taxable savings
so you'd save 262 thousand dollars in
taxes
okay that seems like a pretty
uh good goal for the average hourly
worker
save a thousand dollars put it into your
retirement account we're not even
talking yet about
401k matches and kind of all of the the
complexity that goes with it
500 000 at 55 you said
65 at 65. so basically you would have
about 50 grand to live on
every year until tax-free yeah tax-free
until you get to the average life
expectancy
when people die yeah and look there's
there's obviously other things that go
into it with inflation and all that kind
of stuff but when you think about it in
the grand scheme of the
the median person has 80 to 100 000 this
is
five times as much as that and you're
contributing 83
a month it comes out too the reason i
like the ira too is it protects you from
yourself a little i think people are
just naturally spenders right there's i
think there's
i don't know the stats but i'm sure
there's more people who spend uh more
that actually save
and it just it protects you from
yourself right it's like hey look
i know i can't touch this you can take
like ten thousand dollars out for home
expenses like first-time buyers and
stuff like that
but it's a way to just be like look like
it's one of those things like pay
yourself first
right and i that's why a lot of
companies will just take it out of your
check so it doesn't even hit your
account
you want you contribute bitcoin to your
ira what's no you want some
you want some trillionaire energy you
want some of that if you're living your
life to get to 65
to have 500 000 in your retirement
account and then you're going to live
the last 10 years of your life free
you got the wrong plan in life right
life is hard there's lots of complexity
people are put in really bad situations
you're dealt the wrong hand
all this stuff but if you can change
your mindset and say my goal is not to
wait till i'm 65 years old
and to have 500 000 in my retirement
account and then i get to enjoy the last
10 years of my life when i'm
old and i'm getting older and a lot of
the opportunity
is gone if instead you can make
decisions now when you're young
to put yourself in a position maybe it's
not 65 maybe you can actually do this
when you're
55 or 50 right it doesn't mean that you
have to try to retire at 30 or 35
but what it does mean that is if you can
basically retire at 55 rather than 65
all of a sudden now you got 20 years to
the life expectancy
right rather than only 10 years and so i
think a lot of people especially in
america there's this whole idea of like
i'm going to work for 40 or 50 years and
i'm going to go to work every single day
i'm going to work my ass off i'm going
to get money and then i'm going to
retire i can't wait till i get to
retirement i'm going to get my pension
all this stuff
but if you start to flip it on its head
and say i'm not working
so that then i can go live instead
i'm living and i do the work needed to
be able to live the life i want to live
it completely changes the way that you
think about it and i think that's
probably our biggest message here
is if you want to do the bare minimum
you got to get to 65 years old 61
whatever
pick the age that you want of retirement
and you can't have 100k because you will
not be able to survive
on a material amount of money per year
if you only have 100k in your retirement
but that to me is option two
option one is to make the decisions when
you're young because if you're not
just putting a thousand dollars what if
you're actually investing ten thousand
dollars right which may mean you need a
side job maybe you need two jobs may
mean that you can't go buy something you
want like all the hard stuff you may
have to make the hard personal finance
decisions
but if you can invest the 10 000 rather
than a thousand
and you're able to put that into a
retirement account now you can't because
of some of
the limits et cetera but if you could
and it compounded well guess what
happens you're gonna end up with
millions of dollars in the account
rather than
five hundred thousand but if you don't
want to put in the retirement account
you may just be able to put in the stock
market yes you'll pay taxes on the gains
but you'll still come out on top and so
the whole goal is live your life
enjoy it but don't go buy dumb [ __ ]
instead be able to get the money that
you need in order to invest
and what you find is rich people sure
they own boats cars planes all this
stuff
but the average rich person is more
interested in getting more investments
than they are more material things right
eighty percent of millionaires got
inherited zero dollars 33 percent of
millionaires never
made more than 100k in a single year and
so when you start to look at that data
what it tells you is that the average
millionaire in america
is not running out buying a bunch of
crazy stuff they're learning to invest
their money and that's what's driving
their wealth